in this lesson you are going to
understand the concept of text mining by
the end of this lesson you will be able
to explain text mining execute text
processing tasks so let's go ahead and
understand text mining in detail let's
first understand what text mining is
text mining is the technique of
exploring large amounts of unstructured
text data and analyzing it in order to
extract patterns from the text to data
it is aided by software that can
identify concepts patterns topics
keywords and other attributes in the
data it utilizes computational
techniques to extract and summarize the
high-quality information from
unstructured textual resources let's
understand the flow of text mining there
are five techniques used in text mining
system information extraction or text
pre-processing this is used to examine
the unstructured text by searching out
the important words and finding the
relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation categorization
technique labels the text document under
one or more categories classification of
text data is done based on input output
examples with categorization clustering
or attribute selection clustering method
is used to group text documents that
have similar content clusters are the
partitions and each cluster will have a
number of documents with similar content
clustering makes sure that no document
will be omitted from the search and it
derives all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compactness is indicated using colors
visualization technique helps to display
textual information
in a more attractive way summarization
or interpretation or evaluation
summarization technique will help to
reduce the length of the document and
summarize the details of the documents
it makes the document easy to read for
users and understand the content at the
moment let's understand the significance
of text mining
document clustering document clustering
is an important part of text mining it
has many applications in knowledge
management and information retrieval
clustering makes it easy to group
similar documents into meaningful groups
such as in newspapers where sections are
often grouped as business sports
politics and so on pattern
identification text mining is the
process of automatically searching large
amount of text for text patterns and
recognition of features features such as
telephone numbers and email addresses
can be extracted using pattern matches
product insights text mining helps to
extract large amounts of text for
example customer reviews about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most-loved feature
most-hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitors products
security monitoring text mining helps in
monitoring and extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes text mining
makes sure to use all of your available
information it is a more effective and
productive knowledge discovery that
allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes gather business critical
insights and mitigate operational risk
let's look at the applications of text
mining
speech recognition speech recognition is
the recognition and a translation of
spoken language into text and vice versa
speech often provides valuable
information about the topics subjects
and concepts of multimedia content
information extraction from speech is
less complicated yet more accurate and
precise than multimedia content this
fact motivates content-based speech
analysis for multimedia data mining and
retrieval where audio and speech
processing is a key enabling technology
spam filtering spam detection is an
important method in which textual
information contained in an email is
extracted and used for discrimination
text mining is useful in automatic
detection of spam emails based on the
filtering content using text mining an
email service provider such as Gmail or
Yahoo Mail checks the content of an
email and if some malicious text is
found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis it is done in
order to determine if a given sentence
expresses positive neutral or negative
sentiments sentiment analysis is one of
the most popular applications of text
analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context then on
that with only an objective context
ecommerce personalization text mining is
used to suggest products that fit into a
user's profile text mining is
increasingly being used by e-commerce
retailers to learn more about the
consumers as it is the process of
analyzing textual information in order
to identify patterns and gain insights
ecommerce retailers can target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and discounts to
boost sales and increase customer
loyalty by identifying
customer purchase patterns and opinions
on particular products let's look at
natural language toolkit library in
detail natural language toolkit is a set
of open-source Python models that are
used to apply statistical natural
language processing on human language
data let's see how you can do
environment setup of NLT Kay go to
windows start and launch python
interpreter from anaconda prompt and
enter the following commands enter
command Python to check the version of
Python installed on your system
enter import NLT Kay to link you to the
NLT ke library available to download
then enter NLT KDOT download function
that will open the NLT ke download
window check the download directory
select all packages and click on
download this will download NLT ke on to
your Python once you have downloaded the
NLT ke you must check the working and
functionality of it in order to test the
setup enter the following command in
Python Idol from NLT KDOT corpus import
brown-brown dot word parentheses
parentheses the brown is an NLT ke
corpus that shows the systematic
difference between different genres
available words function will give you
the list available words in the genre
the given output shows that we have
successfully tested the NLT ke installed
on Python
let's now understand how you can read a
specific module from NLT ke corpora if
you want to import an entire module from
NLT ke corpora use asterisk symbol with
that module name import command enter
the command from NLT KDOT book import
asterisk it will load all the items
available in NLT Kay's book module now
in order to explore Brown corpus enter
the command NLT KDOT corpus import Brown
this will import Brown corpus on the
Python
enter Brown dot categories function to
load the different genres available
select a genre and assign that genre to
a variable using the following syntax
variable name is equal to brown dot
words categories is equal to shun
renamed now in order to see the
available words inside the selected
genre just enter the defined variable
name as a command let's understand text
extraction and pre-processing in detail
so let's first understand the concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by its security it is a process of
breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing engrams now let's look at
what Engram is and how it is helpful in
text mining Engram is the simplest model
that assigns these probabilities to
sequences of words or sentences and
grams are combinations of adjacent words
or letters of length and in the source
text so Engram is very helpful in text
mining when it is required to extract
patterns from the text as in the given
example this is a sentence all of these
words are considered individual words
and thus represent yoona grams a to gram
or by gram is a two word sequence of
words like this is is a or a sentence
and a three gram or trigram is a three
word sequence of words like this is a or
is a sentence let's now understand what
stop words are and how you can remove
them
stop words are natural language words
that have negligible meanings such as a
and and or the and other similar words
these words also will take up space in
the database or increase the processing
time so it is better to remove such
words by storing a list of stop words
you can find the list of stop words in
the NLT K data directory that is stored
in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language to find in NLT k
corpus importing NLT k will import the
NLT k corpus for that instance enter
from NLT k corpus import stop words will
import stop words from NLT k corpus now
set the language as English so use set
function as set under braces stop words
dot words set genre as English stop
words are filtered out before processing
of natural language data as they don't
reveal much information so as you can
see in the given example before
filtering the sentence the tokenization
of stop word is processed in order to
remove these stop words and the
filtering is applied in order to filter
the sentence based on some criteria text
extraction and pre-processing stemming
stemming is used to reduce a word to
stem or base word by removing suffixes
such as helps helping helped and help
her to the root word help the stemming
process or algorithm is generally called
a stem er there are various stemming
algorithms such as porter stemmer
lancaster stemmer snowball steamer etc
use any of the stammers defined under n
LT k stem corpus in order to perform
stemming as shown in the example here we
have used porter stemmer when you
observe the output you will see that all
of the words given have been reduced to
their root word or stem text extraction
and pre-processing limit ization limit
ization is the method of grouping the
various inflected types of a word
in order that they can be analyzed as
one item it uses vocabulary list or a
morphological analysis to get the root
word it uses wordnet database that has
English words linked together by their
semantic relationship as you can observe
the given example the different words
have been extracted to their relevant
morphological word using limit ization
text extraction and pre-processing POS
tagging let's now look at different part
of speech tags available in the national
language toolkit library a POS tag is a
special label assigned to each token or
word in a text corpus to indicate the
part of speech and often also other
grammatical categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
etc POS tags are used in text analysis
tools and algorithms and also in corpus
searches so look at the given example
here Alice wrote a program is the source
text given the POS tags given our Alice
is a noun
Road is a verb a is an article and
program is an adjective
look at the given example to understand
how POS tags are defined so the given
sentence or paragraph contains different
words that represent different parts of
speech
we will first use tokenization and
removal of stop words and then allocate
the different POS tags these are shown
with different words in the given
sentence POS tags are useful for limit
is a ssin in building named entity
recognition and extracting relationships
between words text extraction and
pre-processing named entity recognition
now let's understand what named entity
recognition is all about NER seeks to
extract a real-world entity from the
text and sorts it into predefined
categories such as names of people
organizations locations etc many
real-world questions can be answered
with the help of named entity
recognition where specified products
mentioned in complaints or reviews does
the tweet contain the name of
person does the tweet contain the
person's address as you can see in the
given example Google America Larry Page
etc are the names of a person place or
an organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization GPE or
geopolitical entity etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all n ltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step to stop word removal it removes
commonly used words such as the is are
etc which are not relevant to the
analysis step 3 stemming and limit
ization it reduces words to base form in
order to be analyzed as a single item
step four POS tagging it tags words to
be part of speech such as noun verb
adjective etc based on the definition
and context step 5 information retrieval
it extracts relevant information from
the source mo1 Brown corpus problem
statement the Brown University standard
corpus of present-day American English
also known popularly as brown corpus was
compiled in the 1960s as a general
corpus in the field of corpus
linguistics
it contains 500 samples of
english-language text totaling roughly 1
million words compiled from works
published in the United States in 1961
we will be working on one of the subset
data set and perform text processing
tasks let us import the NLT ke library
and read the ca underscore 10 corpus
import NLT ke we will have to make sure
that there are no slashes in between
hence we will use the replace function
within pandas for the same
you
let's have a look at the data once
you
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we obtained
you
similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words tokens
stop word removal let's import the stop
word library from NLT KDOT corpus import
stop words
we also need to ensure that the text is
in the same case n LT K has its own list
of stop words we can check the list of
stop words using stop words dot words
and English inside the parentheses
map the lowercase string with our list
of word tokens
you
let's remove the stop words using the
English stop words list in NLT K we will
be using set checking as it is faster in
Python than a list
by removing all stop words from the text
we obtained
you
often we want to remove the punctuation
from the documents too since Python
comes with batteries included we have a
string dot punctuation from string
import punctuation
you
combining a punctuation with the stop
words from NLT Kay
you
removing stop words with punctuation
you
stemming and delimit ization we will be
using stemming and delimit ization to
reduce words to their root form for
example walks walking walk will be
reduced to their root word walk
importing porter stemmer as the stemming
library from NLT KDOT stem import porter
stemmer
printing the stem words
you
import the word net limit Iser from NLT
KDOT stem
you
printing the root words
you
we also need to evaluate the POS tags
for each token
you
create a new wordlist and store the list
of word tokens against each of the
sentence tokens in data - for i n't Oken
eyes
also we will check if there were any
stop words in the recently created word
list
we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and print
the tagged output
you
for our final text processing task we
will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
etc
you
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we set the parameter
binary equals true then named entities
are just tagged as any otherwise the
classifier adds category labels such as
person organization and GPE
create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity names
we will now extract named entities from
NLT Kay chunked expression and store
them in the empty created above
you
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and we'll extract the
entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked sentences
you
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far one import the NLT
que library to perform tokenization 3
perform stemming and delimit ization 4
remove stop words 5 perform named entity
recognition structuring sentences syntax
let's first understand what syntax is
syntax is the grammatical structure of
sentences in the given example this can
be interpreted as syntax and it is
similar to the ones you use while
writing codes knowing a language
includes the power to construct phrases
and sentences out of morphemes and words
the part of the grammar that represents
a speaker's knowledge of these
structures and their formation is called
syntax phrase structure rules are rules
that determine what goes into a phrase
that is constituents of a phrase and how
the constituents are ordered constituent
is a word or group of words that operate
as a unit and can be used to frame
larger grammatical units the given
diagram represents that a noun phrase is
determined when a noun is combined with
a determiner and the determiner can be
optional a sentence is determined when a
noun phrase is combined with a verb
phrase a verb phrase is determined when
a verb is combined optionally with the
noun phrase and prepositional phrase and
a prepositional phrase is determined
when a preposition is combined with a
noun phrase a tree is a representation
of syntactic structure of formulation of
sentences or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employees 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the syntax
for pairing this statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is employees and the
target is 12.8% which in turn is
modified by Bradford County syntax
parses are often our first step
toward deep information extraction or
semantic understanding of text
rendering syntax trees download the
corresponding dot exe file to install
the ghost script rendering engine based
on your system configuration in order to
render syntax trees in your notebook
let's understand how you can set up the
environment variable once you have
downloaded and installed the file go to
the folder where it is installed and
copy the path of the file now go to
system properties and under advanced
properties you will find the environment
variable button click on that to open
the pop-up box tab of the environment
now open the bin folder and add the path
to the bin folder in your environment
variables now you will have to modify
the path of the environment variable use
the given code to test the working of
syntax tree after the setup is
successfully installed structuring
sentences chunking and chunk parsing the
process of extraction of phrases from
unstructured text is called chunking
instead of using just simple tokens
which may not represent the actual
meaning of the text it is advisable to
use phrases such as Indian team as a
single word instead of Indian and team
as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
correspond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the is the determiner which are chunked
together into a noun phrase
similarly chunk parsing is used to
extract patterns and to process such
patterns from multiple chunks while
using different parsers let's take an
example and try to understand how
chunking is performed in Python let's
consider the sentence the little mouse
ate the fresh cheese assigned to a very
real name descent using the word
tokenized function under n l TK corpora
you can find out the different tags
associated with the sentence provided so
as you can see in the output different
tags have been allocated against each of
the words from the given sentence using
chunking n P chunk and parser you will
now create grammar from a noun phrase
and we'll mention the tags you want in
your chunk phrase within the function
here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjectives followed by a noun you
will now have to parse the chunk
therefore you will create a chunk parser
and pass your noun phrase string to it
the parser is now ready you will use the
parse parentheses parentheses within
your chunk parser to parse your sentence
the sentence provided is the little
mouse eighth of fresh cheese this
sentence has been parsed and the tokens
that match the regular expressions are
chunked together into noun phrases and P
create a verb phrase chunk using regular
expressions the regular expression has
been defined as optional personal
pronoun followed by zero or more verbs
with any of its type followed by any
type of adverb you'll now create another
chunk parser and pass the verb phrase
string to it create another sentence and
tokenize it add POS tags to it so the
new sentence is she is walking quickly
to the mall and the POS tag has been
allocated from NLT que corpora now use
the new verb phrase parser to parse the
tokens and run the results you can look
at the given tree diagram which shows a
verb parser where a pronoun followed by
two verbs and an adverb are chunked
together into a verb parse
structuring sentences chinking chinking
is the process of removing a sequence of
tokens from a chunk
how does chunking work the whole chunk
is removed when the sequence of tokens
spans an entire chunk if the sequence is
at the start or the end of the chunk the
tokens are removed from the start and
end and a smaller chunk is retained if
the sequence of tokens appears in the
middle of the chunk these tokens are
removed leaving two chunks where there
was only one before consider you create
a chinking grammar string containing
three things chunk name the regular
expression sequence of a chunk the
regular expression sequence of your
[ __ ] here in the given code we have the
chunk regular expression as optional
personal pronoun followed by zero or
more occurrences of any type of the verb
type followed by zero or more
occurrences of any of the adverb types
the [ __ ] regular expression says that
it needs to check for the adverb in the
extracted chunk and remove it from the
chunk inside the chinking block with
open curly braces and closing curly
braces you have created one or more
adverbs you will now create a parser
from NLT KDOT reg exp parser and pass
the [ __ ] grammar to it now use the new
[ __ ] parser to parse the tokens sent
three and run the results as you can see
the parse tree is generated while
comparing the syntax tree of the [ __ ]
parser with that of the original chunk
you can see that the token is quickly
adverb chinked out of the chunk let's
understand how to use context-free
grammar a context-free grammar is a four
tuple some NT RS where sum is an
alphabet and each character in sum is
called a terminal and T is a set and
each element in an T is called a
non-terminal R the set of rules is a
subset of n T times the set of some U
and T s the start symbol is one of the
symbols in
and a context-free grammar generates a
language l capturing constituency and
ordering in CFG the start symbol is used
to derive the string you can derive the
string by repeatedly replacing a
non-terminal on the right hand side of
the production until all non terminals
have been replaced by terminal symbols
let's understand the representation of
context-free grammar through an example
in context-free grammar a sentence can
be represented as a noun phrase followed
by a verb phrase noun phrase can be a
determiner nominal a nominal can be a
noun
VP represents the verb phrase a can be
called a determiner flight can be called
a noun
consider the string below where you have
certain rules when you look at the given
context-free grammar a sentence should
have a noun phrase followed by a verb
phrase a verb phrase is a verb followed
by a noun a verb can either be Saul or
met noun phrases can either be John or
Jim and a noun can either be a dog or a
cat check the possible list of sentences
that can be generated using the rules
use the join function to create the
possible list of sentences you can check
the different rules of grammar for
sentence formation using the production
function it will show you the different
tags used and the defined context-free
grammar for the given sentence demo -
structuring sentences problem statement
a company wants to perform text analysis
for one of its data sets you are
provided with this data set named tweets
dot CSV which has tweets of six u.s.
airlines along with their sentiments
positive negative and neutral the tweets
are present in the text column and
sentiments in airline underscore
sentiment column we will be retrieving
all tags starting with at the rate in
the data set and save the output in a
file called references txt let us first
import the pandas library and read the
tweets data set
you
extract the features text and airline
sentiment
we will iterate through the data set
using reg X find the relevant tweets
now we will import the inter tools
module it returns efficient iterators
you
the result is stored in a file named
references dot txt
you
let's extract all noun phrases and save
them in a file named noun phrases for
left caret Airline underscore sentiment
right caret review dot txt
you
here left carrot airline underscore
sentiment right carrot has three
different values positive negative and
neutral so three files will be created
you
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases variable
you
this means that the functions in
itertools operate on iterators to
produce more complex iterators
you
using the map function we will get all
the noun phrases from the text
you
putting it into lists
you
creating a file name in the name of
review txt
you
great we have now seen how to explore
and examine the corpus using text
processing techniques let's quickly
recap the steps we've covered so far one
import the data set to extract a noun
phrases this brings us to the end of
text mining you are now able to explain
text mining execute test processing
tasks hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you